>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joan Weeks: Well, good
afternoon ladies and gentleman.
On behalf of all my colleagues, and
in particular Dr. Mary Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and
Middle Eastern Division,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
So, without further ado then, I'd
like to call upon Fatemeh Keshavarz
to introduce our speaker
and the program today.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Fatemeh Keshavarz: Hi everyone.
I see a lot of young
enthusiastic participants.
That's wonderful.
Welcome. So, I'm trying
to keep this short
so we can actually
get to the program.
I'm Fatemeh Keshavarz.
I'm Director of the School
of Languages, Literatures,
and Cultures, and also Director of
Roshan Institute for Persian Studies
at University of Maryland.
And it's a tremendous pleasure
and honor to be in this series
which involve basically
collaborating very closely
with our wonderful colleagues at
the Library here to bring this,
events such as this one to a much
broader public than we would be able
to do on our own just
through the Institute.
So, that's wonderful.
Thank you.
Mary Jane, Hirad, Joan,
everybody here; that's amazing.
Okay, today, we are hosting a dear
friend of mine and a wonderful,
wonderful artist and educator, a
Maestro, who is also a professor,
and you don't really have very often
these qualities all come together.
And that's Maestro was
saying [foreign language]
or I should sometimes feel bad
that I have to call him professor,
was saying [foreign language],
actually holds a Maseeh
professorship in performing arts
at the University of
California at Irvine.
And he was born in Isfahan in Iran,
grew up in a family in which art
and music was very, very valuable,
and even though he trained
as an architect, he actually
has a Ph.D. degree there,
and later on went to
Florence in Italy
to do further studies
in architecture.
But he also trained as a
ney player and as a musician
in the National Superior
Conservatory of Music
in Genron [phonetic], and he studied
with people like Maestro [inaudible]
and [inaudible], the Master, a
ney player who had a great impact
on Persian music as a whole.
Now, Maestro Omoumi has played
everywhere in World Music Festival,
in San Francisco, in the
Getty Center in Los Angeles,
and you know in Asia
society in New York.
I'm not really going to have the
time to go through all of that.
I would like to tell you that
the film that you're going
to see is going to teach a lot
more than just music and him.
It's about the human relationship
that makes this, the transmission
of this art possible as well
as the intricacies of the art.
So, I don't know if the
copies are available,
but I would highly recommend for you
to go online and get copies of this.
It's called Classical Persian Music,
and it's about from
Isfahan to Irvine.
There was actually, this
was made with, first of all,
support from NEH, and then later
on from Roshan Cultural
Heritage Institute.
So, we are delighted to
have played a role in that.
I think without further ado,
I would like to invite --
are you, Hirad, going
to say anything,
or was it -- just a second.
Okay. My friend Hirad is going
to say a couple of words,
and then we're going
to see the film,
and then we will actually
meet Maestro Omoumi.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank you,
everyone, for joining us.
I also wanted to give you a heads
up on the Persian, essentially,
Persian Book Lecture Series.
We have another wonderful program
coming up next week on Tuesday.
Kevin Shorts will be speaking about
Persian in the 18th, 19th century,
and the finale for this
year is in November,
November 9th, the day
after elections.
This one is Hamid Dabashi's new
work, Persophilia, essentially,
the Love of Things Persian.
So, I just wanted to mention that to
you so you can put it on your notes,
and I also want to take a
second here and thank all of you
for showing up on a busy
weekday, especially during lunch,
and especially from
Fortismere and University
of Maryland's wonderful staff
for always working
hand and glove with us.
Thank you very much.
We'll start the film now.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: I want to thank
everyone for coming, attending,
and I especially thank you for
being here during lunch hour
because I know everyone's busy.
So, my request is to ask
Maestro Omoumi to come up.
[ Applause ]
>> Hirad Dinavari: Thank you
very much for coming here.
It's a huge honor.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hossein Omoumi: Thank you.
>> Hirad Dinavari: And I'm going
to ask for a few questions.
I know we're a little over an
hour, but unfortunately we got
to start late because of
traffic and everything.
So, if it's okay, feel free to
get up and ask a few questions.
Dr. Amoki Makouk [phonetic],
go ahead.
>> Dr. Amoki Makouk: I just wanted
to point out a happy coincidence
that this park and this event
last was used [inaudible]
in [inaudible] in literature.
For too long, we are
unduly separation of quality
and music is strong in all of it,
and I think it really behooves
us all to do whatever we can
to reconcile these two because
in the future the Persian history
you'll see will always be
[inaudible] minstrel [inaudible]
tradition is all the time and that
he had talked [inaudible] here
to enjoy this report
they were just reading.
I think it was a book
or a novel, in fact.
This shows that that quality is
separable from songs and music
in the one [inaudible]
at the arts tradition.
Thank you very much.
>> Hirad Dinavari: All
right, a question anyone?
Thank you, Dr. Kaimi [phonetic].
Go ahead, Joan.
>> Joan: I love that
you're an innovator.
I love innovation and all of the
new ways that you were thinking
of the instruments and ways to
use it, and the language, poetry,
and I saw that something that
almost looked like Latin, you say.
Could you describe other
innovations perhaps
where you've taken the lyrics
and tried to merge [inaudible]?
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah.
That's a great idea, actually.
WE were into core and know
there was play, what was that?
>> Joan: That was it.
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah, it was drat
[phonetic], but today we're talking
about the history of America
with drat for the children.
So, actually, I'm asking
the port to compose the poem
for Pischardif [phonetic]
and for the kids.
So, I'm waiting for the poem
to adapt it; then for the kids
to sing this poem and learn music
through the poetry for the children.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Hamid Dabashi: In line with that,
you've done a lot with [inaudible]
and with the classical, [inaudible]
give the ones he has done on the,
on the [inaudible] opening parts
of the National [inaudible]
so focused on name.
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah.
>> And then combining the
meeting and the -- I love that.
>> This is a long story,
actually, yeah.
>> I can't say how much
I enjoyed [inaudible],
but I wanted to ask you something.
You wrote an [inaudible].
Are there modern poems in which
that you would get to the music?
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah, sure.
Yeah. The amount, the huge number
of the melodic patterns that we have
in classical Persian music, there's
some part that we have freedom
to choose any kind of poetic
freedom, and we can see
and perform neo-poetry in
classical Persian music in that part
of classical Persian music.
But there are some
parts that are based
on the classical Persian
poetry, and classical rhythm,
so we must keep this
poetry of rhythm.
But where we have freedom,
we can use modern poetry.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah.
>> Hossein Omoumi:
Yeah, I have sang it.
One of the poem of
[inaudible], not of all of them.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> It's music.
>> Hossein Omoumi: So, yeah.
[ Singing in Foreign Language ]
>> Hossein Omoumi: It's long.
[ Applause ]
>> Hossein Omoumi: Yeah, I
was singing by [inaudible].
I was singing [inaudible].
It has a name, Biota
Roge [phonetic], so.
>> Hirad Dinavari: Wonderful!
Thank you very much, everyone.
I really wish we could take more
time, but we have to head out.
It's already been over an hour.
Thank you very much
again for attending,
and don't forget we have two more
lectures coming up for this year;
one next week and one in November.
And Maestro, thank you very much.
You've honored us with this.
>> Hossein Omoumi: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.loc.gov.